[Musique]
mais déjà ça qui me plaît de la vie si
tous kankan est astucieux mais
cette issue le plus sérieux n'avait pas
joué il s'est mis de vouloir devenir
amis
alors un enfant oui bonjour tout confort
bonjour bonjour fabry bonjour à tous et
à toutes
je suis fou de joie je suis fou de joie
parce que je dis trouver un nouveau jeu
à l'esc rue du petit pois danseurs à le
petit pois dans ce qu'est ce qu'il faut
pour jouer à ça il faut te vas regarde
j'ai tout à porter sur ton bureau un
tube de studio abbey par exemple vinh et
plus vides vides et un petit point oui
enfin là c'est pas un petit pois c'est
une seule espèce de petit cacahuètes aux
fachos pas trop ce que c'est mais c'est
un truc un peu rond ça peut se remplacer
avantageusement par un petit point chez
vous si vous en avez alors il sait il
faut faire quoi maintenant alors tu
poses le petit poire sur le bout du tube
we le tube tu l'as proche de ta bouche
tu mets ta tête en arrière pour souffler
et le petit bois va se mettre à danser
5,6 à ses assurés
voilà souffle bien tu penses mn ans et
il tombe
voilà il tombe alors maintenant
explications pourquoi ton style bon quoi
ton style pas répondu parce qu'il ne
tient pas non c'est pas du tout ça parce
qu'ils tiennent il ya un petit truc est
un vrai petit pas alors je vais prendre
un autre petit poids à la voilà les
premiers enfin un frein historiens font
quand j'en recommande brise dans le
petit pois dans les souffles bien je
t'en prie mais comme je peux moi je
souffre et toi voilà ça tourne ça tourne
or ces produits sains et l'autre en
hiver vous avez vous avez compris le
truc on avait compris le truc est
extrêmement simple regardez tenait le
petit pois il tient très bien pourquoi
tu y at-il tout simplement parce que
nous avons mis planté dans le petit pot
dans la cacahuète une épingle ou une
aiguille c'est exactement ça qu'il
fallait faire et ça marche très très
bien vous venez de le voir c'est pas
compliqué mais cet astucieux un
astucieux bravo tout cas encore tu dois
bien payé comme tous j'ai beaucoup
soufflé maintenant il faut que je me
détende un peu parce que chez nous je
vais éclater alors on attend jardin le
jardin adam jardin je suis moi je vais
te préparer un point commun tu va voir
qui est assez astucieux aussi à huy elle
a ensuite rappelé les enfants me voilà à
faire notre fidèle au rendez vous tiens
la forme et tout le temps bien fait bien
on appelle au on appelle la vraie vie
c'est oui oui allez avoir entendu
quelque chose mais seigneur bonsoir que
m'avait vous préparez le point commun je
pensais rappelons que vous êtes des
choses différentes dont vous allez nous
parler et notre problème consiste à
deviner quel est le point commun qui lie
à entre eux ces choses différentes que
vous allez être dans quelques secondes
exactement
alors je commence et je suis la terre je
suis toute la terre d'ailleurs tout
c'est seulement là terme à la mer je
représente la terre ferme
tous les endroits où on peut habiter
circuler en voiture à pied en bicyclette
ou à dos de chameau et là où on a besoin
d'une barque
je n'existe plus vois-tu pour que tu
comprennes bien je suis l'europe l'asie
l'afrique l'amérique et l'océanie
ce qui ce qui n'est déjà pas si mal un
bon seuil imagine ce que je représente
comme pays comme désert comme montagne
comme grandes villes et comme petites
routes
il en faut du temps pour connaître tous
ces continents quels gens présents sur
ben voila je m'arrête là c'est tout faux
faux qu'avec ça tu te donnes est facile
je si cette main que tu vois là
j'exagère
quand je dis cette meuf je ne suis
qu'une partie de cette manne je suis
seulement les doigts de cette manne
tu les connais bien ses doigts fabrice
le pousse le plus gros poste
il indexe celui avec lequel on indique
par exemple la direction à suivre
et puis le méduses qui s'appelle comme
ça parce qu'il est situé au milieu et
ensuite il y à l'annulaire
on vient donner ce nom parce que c'est à
ce doigt qu'on place généralement un
anneau une balle et on fait le véhicule
air qui doit son nom au fait qu'il est
le seul c'est petit pour s'introduire
dans nos règles très bien alors et toi
post je suis parce que pour l'instant je
dois te dis mais je n'ai rien trouvé un
bon moi je vais essayer de t d avait du
ca m'a alors malheureusement
malheureusement je suis assez compliqué
mangal je peux faire des tas de choses
je peux regarder ce qui m'entoure grâce
à mes yeux je peux sentir les fleurs qui
sont autour de moi
grâce à mon nez je peux goûter les
aliments grâce à mon palais oui je peux
entendre tous les oiseaux de la forêt
grâce à mes oreilles et enfin je peux
toucher les feuilles les arbres les
brins d'herbe grâce à mes pattes
en somme je suis la vue l'ouïe l'odorat
le goût et le toucher
on appelle ça des saints qui a compris
package halal ça caillait un tagueur
c'est ça jusqu'ici je nageais un bras et
c'est grâce à toi je suis bien aidé j'ai
trouvé alors je le dis oui le point
commun et qui existe entre tous conquis
et les continents entre bell bell qui
les voit la main et pousse moussu oui
les 106 cm et vitrolles aa c'est le
nombre 5 les 50 années on voit les cinq
à l'école c'est bien j'ai pas s'il va
être aussi futée que ça avec moi je suis
dans mon petit j'ai musique je vais
faire un effort préparer des nets à ma
façon
c'est à nous de maintenant chez nous
deux on va jouer a dit que oui devine ce
que j'ai oublié
et bah alors là je vais le deviner tout
de suite ton crayon exactement le
chercher sur l'établi evans chercheurs
pensent et voilà ça c'est fréquent jeu
l'oubli tout le temps oui alors bon
alors cette semaine
tu as un mot en cette lettre où cette
lettre doit laisser pas trop long à la
vallée cette lettre on commence par la
première c'est un m
or m comme marcel et après alors cinq
petits traits comme d'habitude alors un
3 4 5 et la dernière un ace voilà coop
et je t'écoute un animal non un arbre
non c'est pas feint pas exactement ça ça
pousse sur les arbres si tu veux une
fleur ou un fait qu'est ce que tu as dit
une fleur oui libre à vous une fleur tu
fais des progrès en fleur et je vois
quand on est que ce peuple orthographe
tu n'es pas très sûr d'abord encore tu
veux tu veux que ça donne une lettre
supplémentaire oui n'essaie pas de
détourner la conversation noulin la
troisième l'aide si tu veux oui c'est
quoi c'est encore un m encore oui
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être que ça
c'est ça sent bon
oui oui c'est rouvrir un cheyrou genou
ces bleus n'ont plus sévère non je suis
dit la couleur c'est jaune 8 à trouver
là c'est jaune c'est journée ça sent
très bon ces jeux
mais ils sont très bons oui il y en a
beaucoup dans le midi bah écoute
étant donné la place des 2 m moi
j'aurais pensé immédiate on a mis mozart
et bah voilà ben oui mais alors me rosa
et ça ne s'écrit pas comme ça me mozac
promo su ça commence un mimosa bas est
effrayant il ne progresse absolument et
c'est souvent avec la fin des mots où
j'ai raté mon nain l'aï pas beau à tête
parce qu'il est franchement rien n'est
pas tellement mieux d'ailleurs là ça me
bouffe ça s'écrit comme sa section
écrivait comme lille a annon mozin
romana peut être excusable limites parce
que c'est vrai que lille après un ace à
la wii et audi des mimosas
oui mais nîmes houba windows à ça
s'écrit comme ça en tout cas battu
toulon en apprend des choses non on
apprend enfin je viens de pardonner
cette fois c'est bon à la limite faire
une erreur sur ce limogeage
bon bah loin pour l'apprendre à prendre
une chose moi oui mais tu apprends d'une
chose c'est que le mimosa
c'est une variété d'acacia à savais pas
ça et que l'acacia c'est un arbre que
les fourmis aime beaucoup
elles y trouvent une nourriture dont
elle se régale et on raconte même que
enfin ça franchement je n'ai jamais vu
mais que dans certains cas si un homme
ou un animal abîme un acacia
elles sont tellement en colère qu'elle
attaque à l attaque celui qui a fait ça
paie et trois mois des des fourmis qui
attaque un c c'est dangereux ou le nord
mais en tout cas en tout cas même si
c'est pas vrai ben moi je trouve qu'il
faut jamais abîmer les arbres tu as
raison un fût raison que tu absolument
rezala suis d'accord avec toi voilà tu
t'agites tout con con tu t'agites parce
que il a rappelé qu'il est comme moi il
a d'aller rencontrer belle bella
d'écouté surtout allongé en musique à
l'onu
la faf a bouffé ce que j'ai fait c'est
vrai si la musique tu verras que tu dois
[Musique]
résister aux deux plateaux
c'est l'adopter on n'a pas imaginé
thèmes ont fait faux bond pour notre
petit jeu des bonnes notes cher petit
fabrice mais je voudrais te demander
d'être particulièrement gentil à mon
égard je me sens un peu thing et on peut
signer je suis très choquée elle
étudiait la malheureuse et les tig et
elle est peut-être fatigué n'est ce pas
oui et je sais pas ce que j'ai depuis
quelques jours je me sens prise une
grande étude grandeur du doigt oui d'une
grande attend la wii
après si je quitte sud
voilà c'est que j'ai fait tellement
d'efforts en installant mon nouvel
appartement évidemment je ne
transportait pas des caisses de 100 kg
boudy ses billets à que tout est positif
tout est lié non tout est rôdé pièce ja
oui
ja rule oui un camarade hakim qui teste
is normal oui au affectif à la fin on
peut encore deviné ça doit être relatifs
où il relate il relaté jouer c'était
mieux soutient bernard et sinon on
n'aurait pas pu jouer
bon donc j'ai passé mes journées à aller
venir angers nettoyant fin à courir sans
arrêt et ont séduit
oui vous l'avez partout ll n'y a rien
d'autre qu'une commande de nourriture et
moi je tiens ça me fatigue un jeu ça
recommence la phrase je suis allé
partout j'ai couru sans arrêt et
alors ça pourrait être d'après ce que tu
me dis j'ai couru partout mais c'est ici
et là oui ça c'est tiré par les cheveux
finalement j'ai décidé de prendre une
grande blum blum cyan et là c'est très
très dur mais c'est une astuce tu ne
trouveras jamais m'a fait ça m'amuse
énormément envoyé depuis que j'ai pris
cette grande blonde l'option s'est il
tout à fait bien battu a pris une grande
tiens tu vas voir et au sol
oui et alors aux finesses ce n'est pas
le dos mais c'est le but restant le
premier se ri pak sillon celui là il est
encore pire le physalis sur salat je ne
suis pas fait pour les efforts physiques
puisque je ne suis pas capable de
supporter sur mes faibles épaules de
lourds fardeaux
oui très bien bon d'écouter d'être est
prêtre est parfait aujourd'hui j'étais
cours vie à faire avec moi un petit tour
de chant minuscule tu connais ma petite
chance qu'on est bien entendu
les quatre amis déjà papa d'amy l'état
toute la vie vous diront qu'ils se
plaignent que la vie majeur s'est
désisté et rzeszow fait des choses mais
comme juni pas de mine war negro à faire
attention les cartes à mi parcours de
son oeil dit les quatre ça me sens
heureux d'arisem la vie
oui
il
mon pays
alors
aujourd'hui vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]